a strict mode in JavaScript tightens the
rules for certain behaviors these
restrictions keep code safer and
sometimes help JavaScript engines
perform optimizations you can execute
JavaScript code in strict mode by using
the use strict directive there are two
ways to use strict mode you can apply it
to your entire file by putting you
strict as the first line in your file
here's an example of that even before
this comment I'm going to put use strict
and now this entire file will be run in
strict mode you can also apply strict
mode to individual functions by putting
use strict at the first line in a
function here's an example of that see
we have you strict as the first line of
the function and then we have all the
other lines of the function strict mode
is going to convert mistakes or bad
syntax into real errors in normal
JavaScript mistyping a variable name
creates a new global variable however in
strict mode this will throw an error
making it impossible to accidentally
create a global variable if you look up
here at this example this is going to
create an error in strict mode in strict
mode you have to first declare a
variable with var Const or let before
you can assign a value to it so I could
put bar y equals 3.14 and now this will
not create an error also in strict mode
deleting a variable is not allowed it is
allowed in normal mode in normal
JavaScript a developer will not receive
any error feedback assigning values to
non writable properties in strict mode
in the assignment to a non writable
property a getter only property a
non-existing property a non-existing
variable or a non-existing object will
throw an error so this is an example of
trying to write to a non writable
property we've created this property X
and we've set writable to false so you
should not be able to change that value
to 3.14 and in strict mode that will
create an error now here's an example of
trying to write
to a Gitter only property so this is a
get property so you should only be able
to get it you shouldn't be able to
assign a new value to it
so in strict mode that will throw an
error also strict mode makes attempting
to delete undeletable properties throw
an error where before the attempt would
simply just have no effect you cannot
delete object at prototype that's going
to throw an error in a normal mode it
would not delete just would have no
effect in strict mode function parameter
names must be unique so if you have a
function like this and we use strict in
the function or even if the whole file
is using strict you can't have two A's
as parameters this is going to be wrong
because it's probably just a mistake
right here you're trying to return a
plus B plus C but we have a a C so
that's just gonna give a syntax error
there are also changes to width and eval
in strict mode the width statement
extends the scope chain for a statement
strict mode prohibits with completely
the problem with width is that any name
inside the block might map either to a
property or the object passed to it or
to a variable n surrounding or even
global scope at runtime it's impossible
to know beforehand so when we use width
here that means we're going to add the
scope to whatever we passed in as a
parameter to all the code within the
width block if this were not strict mode
would this X refer to var X or would it
refer to objects because we passed in
it's actually impossible to say without
running the code so the name can't be
optimized so prohibiting the use of
width makes optimization better the
other changes with eval in strict mode
eval does not introduce new variables
into the surrounding scope so in normal
code if you have eval so if you have
eval var X that's going to introduce a
variable X into the surrounding function
or the global scope in strict
eval creates variables only for the code
being evaluated so eval can't affect
whether a name refers to an outer
variable or some local variable this VAR
X is only going to exist right in this
little section of code here so outside
of that there will not be any of our X
so here's another example of that we're
gonna set X to 17 and for about X we are
going to eval all the code from within
here so we're gonna evaluate that code
and you can see it's it's strictmode VAR
x equals 42 and x we're gonna pass back
X to eval X so in normal mode putting
var x equals 42 within this eval
statement is going to change the X we
put up here to 17 however in strict mode
X is still going to equal 17 and eval X
is now gonna equal 42 because this X
that we're passing back to eval X is
completely different than this X also
strict mode makes it easier to write
secure JavaScript in browsers it's no
longer possible to reference the window
object through this inside of strict
mode function and strict mode makes it
impossible to easily access the most
recently called function and the
arguments used to run a function these
features of strict mode have a lot of
security advantages because of the
security advantages and because it helps
with ITER's a lot of people recommend
that you always use strict mode on your
code well those are the basics of strict
mode thanks for watching my name is beau
Carnes don't forget to subscribe and
remember use your code for good